- You can grow mint in the ground
but this is where we have
our disclaimer for mint.
Mint is a very aggressively growing plant.
That means that where you plant mint
it will expand and it will
pop up all over your garden.
So my tip for you in growing mint
is to either grow it in a pot
or grow it in a raised bed.
If you don't want to dedicate
a whole raised bed to mint
you can actually bury a pot in the soil
and that will help keep mint in this area.
We're gonna take your pot
and your pot can be as big as you want
if you want a bigger section of mint.
If it's at soil level
the runners would expand
right across the soil.
So you wanna leave it high
up, keeping your mint in check
if you don't want it to take over.
(upbeat music)